THIS IS HAPPENING AT EVERY STOP
THAT HE HAS, WHICH BRINGS US TO
A VERY IMPORTANT OBSERVATION
WITH JUST SEVEN DAYS TO GO UNTIL
ELECTION DAY.
DEMOCRATS, ALLIES, THEY MEDIA
MOB ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN POSSIBLY DO TO DEMORALIZE
VOTERS ESPECIALLY SUPPORTERS OF
THE PRESIDENT AND DESPITE MAJOR
PROGRESS IN OUR FIGHT AGAINST
COVID-19 INCLUDING ADVANCEMENTS
THAT ARE HUGE AND THERAPEUTICS,
MULTIPLE FINAL HUMAN STAGE
TRIALS FOR A VACCINE COURTESY OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S OPERATION WARP
SPEED, A REBOUNDING ECONOMY
EXPECTING MASSIVE THIRD-QUARTER
GDP NUMBERS THIS WEEK ON
THURSDAY DESPITE ALL OF THE GOOD
NEWS, THERE IS NOW A CONSTANT
CORONAVIRUS HYSTERIA 24/7 ON
EVERY OTHER NEWS NETWORK THAT
WANT YOU TO BELIEVE THERE IS NO
HOPE UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IN FACT ACCORDING TO THE MEDIA
RESEARCH CENTER, 92% OF ALL
NETWORK NEWS COVERAGE OF THE
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN NEGATIVE.
THAT’S 92% AND A RIGHT ON CUE,
JOE BIDEN PREDICTING THE DARK
WINTER AND LESS HE WILL ELECT
HIM.
APPARENTLY NOBODY’S TOLD HIM
ABOUT THE THERAPEUTICS AND THE
VACCINES THAT WERE VERY CLOSE TO
GETTING.
THAT’S RIGHT, THE COGNITIVELY
STRUGGLING THE WEAK, FRAIL,
77-YEAR-OLD WHO OFTEN DOESN’T
EVEN REMEMBER WHO HE’S RUNNING
AGAINST IS SOMEHOW GOING TO
INSTANTLY RESCUE AMERICA FROM
COVID-19.
TODAY, BIDEN ACCIDENTALLY CALLED
HIS RUNNING MATE’S HUSBAND OR
WIFE.
AS IT SEEMS TO HAPPEN EVERY TIME
HE MISSES HIS NAP AND YESTERDAY,
STRUGGLED MIGHTILY TO ANSWER A
SIMPLE UNSCRIPTED QUESTION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HERE’S THE DEAL, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT IS IMPORTANT IS THAT
KEEP IN MIND ALTHOUGH THEY ARE
GOING TO VOTE ON BARRETT I THINK
TODAY.
>> Sean: THAT’S THE GUY THAT’S
GOING TO SAVE THE WORLD FROM
EVERYTHING.
HIS STATED PLANS ON COVID FOR
EXAMPLE HAVE ALREADY BEEN
COMPLETED AND COMPLETELY
IMPLEMENTED ALREADY DONE BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
MAYBE HE MISSED IT.
HE WAS NAPPING THE WHOLE TIME
HIDING IN HIS BASEMENT.
JOE IS BARELY ABLE TO LEAVE THAT
BUNKER FOR MORE THAN ONE DAY AT
A TIME IN EFFECT AS OF NOW, NO
PUBLIC EVENT SCHEDULED FOR JOE
TOMORROW, LESS THAN ONE WEEK
AWAY FROM THE ELECTION, JOE
STILL CONSTANTLY TAKING DAYS
OFF.
THE MEDIA MOB WANTS YOU TO THINK
JOE HAS IT IN THE BAG,
CONSTANTLY TOUTING POLLS SAYING
JOE WAS IN THE LEAD AND NO
CHANCE FOR TRUMP KEEP IN MIND
THESE ARE THE SAME POLLS THAT
GOT IT WRONG IN 2016.
COMING UP ON THIS PROGRAM, WE
WILL TALK TO TWO POSTERS THAT
ACTUALLY GOT IT RIGHT IN 2016.
WE WILL GET THEIR TAKE ON THE
STATE OF THE RACE.
ONE IS ROBERT FROM THE TRAFALGAR
GROUP WHO IS NOW SHOWING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE LEAD IN
MICHIGAN, ALSO SHOWING A LEAD
FOR THE PRESIDENT IN
PENNSYLVANIA AND NEARLY A
THREE-POINT LEAD IN THE STATE OF
NORTH CAROLINA, VERY IMPORTANT
STATE.
MEANWHILE, SHOWING A ONE POINT
LEAD FOR BIDEN IN WISCONSIN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WINS ANY
COMBINATION OF THOSE STATES, HE
WILL BE WELL ON HIS WAY TO
REELECTION BUT AS YOU CAN SEE,
THE MARGINS ARE LIKE 2016
RAZOR-THIN, ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN.
MY ADVICE TO ALL OF YOU, YOU’RE
THE ULTIMATE JURY, ASSUME THAT
YOUR VOTE WILL BE DECIDING VOTE.
IF EVERYONE WANTS TO STOP THE
RADICAL BIDEN-HARRIS ANTI-FOSSIL
FUEL HIGHER TAXES OPEN BORDER
AMNESTY PACKING THE COURT AGENDA
YOU’RE GOING TO NEED TO VOTE AND
ACCORDING TO THE HILL, DEMOCRATS
ARE NOW UNDERPERFORMING IN EARLY
VOTING IN THREE CRITICAL SWING
STATES.
THAT WILL BE FLORIDA, IOWA, AND
NEVADA AND KEEP IN MIND THE
ENTHUSIASM GAP IS ENORMOUS.
JOE BIDEN IS LUCKY TO HAVE A
DOZEN PEOPLE IN THE EVENT EVEN
WITH JON BON JOVI AND MEANWHILE
EVERYWHERE THE PRESIDENT GOES,
HE IS GREETED BY MASSIVE
HISTORIC UNPRECEDENTED CROWDS,
SUPPORTERS WAITING IN LINE,
HOURS AND HOURS EVEN SLEEPING
OVERNIGHT TO HEAR THE PRESIDENT
SPEAK, HIS RALLIES ARE HELD AT